um which is interesting um i and
actually this is what i want to talk
about is the kind of discourse and
conversation between
um you know kind of
more
theoretical concepts and more kind of
real world understanding of uh you know
topics complicated technology
and so
uh
hopefully we can have a conversation
with the four of us and maybe a couple
people on zoom if they have any
questions everybody should feel free to
chime in
um
i
you know i'm i uh
um
i wanna talk about sort of thinking like
a journalist as as i titled this
but i also
want to work through some of the
topics that i've written about and how
they might be interesting to people
at the institute if they
ever listen to this um and i will
uh so so and then we can just have a
conversation along the way you guys
should again feel free to just chime in
and ask me questions so um
i
um
yes so my just you know to to get out of
the way sort of my
my story i i came from
my first job in journalism was actually
at a jewish newspaper called the forward
in new york and i worked there for
about eight years
before i started in new york before i
started covering wall street right after
the financial crisis
for the la times initially and then the
new york times brought me over to
write for them and in the course of um
writing about finance and markets for
the new york times i
sort of happened upon the story uh the
early rise of bitcoin and it was in this
nebulous area between
finance and markets and technology and
nobody quite knew what to do with it or
whether to take it seriously
and i happen upon it and it's i thought
i was just gonna write a story or two
and it would disappear um but i've ended
up
you know really over the last seven
years focusing increasingly on this sort
of bizarre world of
cryptocurrencies and
blockchains and everything else that's
come out of them
um
and um
you know the centerpiece of that was
this book on the history of bitcoin
called digital gold um
but i've continued covering it right up
until today and the rise of
decentralized finance and nfts and
dows decentralized autonomous
organizations so um uh it's it's an odd
area that i've ended up covering it's
even odd to me in a way that i've ended
up covering it and it's i think there's
a lot of people who
uh sort of view it as some weird you
know kind of digital pet rock bitcoin
um
but uh it
actually the way i got ended up here at
the simons institute was that um
one of the
um professor scientists here alessandro
cheza
was one of the inventors of zcash which
is a privacy focused um cryptocurrency
and he actually initially invited me
here to talk to his class
about you know the rise of bitcoin and
the story and how you know scientists
might interact with people around this
topic um
and his this paper is this uh
cryptocurrency that's based on zk snarks
which are becoming increasingly
important in the world of
cryptocurrencies for privacy um and
um
so it's uh it's a topic that ranges very
high and very low you know on the one
hand you've got these like
boozy bitcoin cruises and on the other
hand you have high-end theoretical
computer science that's thinking about
these issues um so um i'm going to start
uh just by talking about
i i want to you know end up with sort of
how i approach problems as a journalist
but i'm going to start actually by
talking about the evolution of bitcoin
and the application to some of the areas
that
the simons institute is thinking about
including causality and game theory
and
i think there is an opportunity this is
an area of research that's probably
you know it's an of increasing
interest and concern to academics but i
think there's a lot here to explore
so
i'll just start by noting that um
bitcoin was created in 2009 right after
the collapse of uh lehman brothers the
the fight in the midst of the financial
crisis and the idea was to create this
new kind of electric money that wouldn't
have to go through intermediaries like
lehman brothers like central banks that
you could just send money from one
digital address to another
like you can do with email so sort of
creating a kind of money that would work
in the way that email does
and in the first block uh the the
genesis block of bitcoin um
this there was this language uh from the
day was actually a few days before it
got going uh a headline from the times
you know chancellor on the brink of
second bailout of banks and so right
there from the beginning
was this
notion that this was responding to the
crisis the the weakness of banks the way
the governments were handling banks at
the time
um
and um
the you know this was digital money in a
sense uh sort of no different than maybe
paypal money uh paypal dollar is digital
obviously all of the dollars in our bank
accounts are digital
but you know in the traditional world
when you digitize money you need a
central intermediary to keep track of
the ledger of where all of that money is
you know whose account it's in you need
somebody keeping track of that because
it's digital it's not physical um and so
uh bitcoin was an effort to
create a system that would make it
possible to send money directly without
needing that
and that's obviously where
um cryptography comes in um you know the
the basis of these addresses
is uh public key private key
cryptography that's what makes it
possible to have an address to to log
into that address to get access to that
address and the bitcoins in it
without uh without any third party
needing to know your your password or
where your money is
so um that is um
that is the idea this is actually a shot
from yesterday of um the bitcoin
blockchain as transactions are coming in
um it's a hash of each transaction
uh the the two addresses are not here
but if you hit that hash you would get
the two addresses you know so here 110
dollars was being sent 95 000 18 260 000
in one transaction and these are the
transactions that are being broadcast
across the network
i think you probably have all heard of
the blockchain the blockchain is just
where every transaction is
recorded
and um you know beyond this idea of two
addresses that can talk to each other
you can email money as you could email
you can send money like you could send
an email
the um
the other piece of this is that you have
a public ledger on which every
transaction
is recorded um and this um this is uh
this is this this idea of the blockchain
a public public ledger of every
transaction
is i would think for this center for
machine learning an incredible
you you get you can see every
transaction that happens as it happens
where it was sent
the kinds of fees that were involved
and um
this is i mean i think for sort of
machine learning for data scientists
this is a pretty unusual sort of
opportunity and source because
you know most banks are not going to
just give you all of their records of
their financial transactions here you
have um an endless ledger that tells you
every transaction that's happened back
to day one
um
so uh this
uh i'll just take you here to
um
the notion that the people keeping these
records um you know instead of having a
central institution you have uh instead
of having a central institution that
keeps track of every bitcoin you have a
bunch of nodes across the world that
anybody can join and
these nodes uh are
incentivized to to join the network and
help keep track of transactions
by being given new bitcoin so every 10
minutes a block of new bitcoins is given
to a bitcoin miner as they're known
somewhere around the world
and um these bitcoin miners are
uh basically keeping track of that that
that ledger that we were looking at
and um and in return they are given you
know right now i think it's or i think
we're at either 12.5 or 7.5 bitcoins um
uh every 10 minutes and um
and the
the the number of computers the amount
of computing power is what secures the
network um and so you're incentivized to
join the network this also provides a
way to distribute new coins so
this is how every bitcoin has ever been
distributed it's to miners on the
network this particular one is a set of
mining computers is
in russia which is particularly
interesting when it comes to
cryptocurrencies in bitcoin today
because
um russia is obviously thinking and
talking about uh bitcoin as a way around
american sanctions you know the notion
that they might get cut off from swift
and not be able to send dollars um you
know the nature of bitcoin is that they
will likely continue to be able to send
bitcoins across the network
um so this notion of miners keeping
track of of um
of
of this ledger and every transaction
happened as i mentioned
is um i think this incredible source of
information
that has has only sort of started to be
mined by scientists to understand there
there are the main companies that do
this right now
do it to help the government basically
track down criminals who are using
bitcoin track down russian oligarchs who
are using um bitcoin
you know invasion of u.s sanctions um
and and a bunch of these there are a
bunch of these companies that have
become very valuable chain analysis is
the one that i've actually dealt with
and used the most they're very helpful
at sort of working through the geography
of payments and cryptocurrency networks
um but um again it's sort of a nascent
area of research that
i think offers a lot to computer
scientists um so i
though am coming at this um more from
the perspective of the human stories and
i think
you know how did bitcoin come to be
um there's one piece of it which is the
technology the the the blockchain um
public key private public private key
cryptography um you know there's a lot
there for computer scientists one of the
interesting things as i've talked to
computer scientists over time is how
the human
tail of bitcoin kind of diverges at
points from what you might expect given
the incentives of the network
and actually i think this is where
you know game theory um comes into play
and i think there's a lot of interesting
game theory around the incentives set up
in these networks um
[Music]
come on in
um so i um
you know i have been focused on the sort
of
the my book about bitcoin was about the
the story the culture of how it
developed and how this emerged
and you know again to understand that
part of it is understanding the
technology but another part of it is
understanding the people involved
i think for the first two years one of
the most interesting parts of the
bitcoin story is the first two years
when
bitcoin were essentially worth nothing
um and there were some computers hooked
into the network mining bitcoin
um
and they each every 10 minutes they
would get 50 bitcoins delivered to them
because they were helping keep that
record of transactions
um at points there were you know five or
ten computers and if they had all turned
off their computers
the recording of the transactions would
have stopped bitcoin would have stopped
um and the the biggest source of
computing power in those first two years
was
from the creator of bitcoin
known as satoshi nakamoto
a sort of ongoing mystery
we still don't know who satoshi nakamoto
is there have been lots of guesses and i
have my sort of best guess as to who it
might be but satoshi's computers kept it
going um uh and satoshi mined something
like uh a million bitcoin um there are
20 there will ever be 21 million we're
now up to i think 18.9 million bitcoins
that have been mined
um satoshi's addresses have about a
million of them they've never moved
they're worth
uh uh billions of dollars what's a
million dollars times forty thousand a
million bitcoins times forty thousand
dollars is approximately the value of
satoshi's bitcoins they're sitting there
in
his addresses and people kind of monitor
them to see if those
bitcoins ever move
um but during those first two years
pretty much satoshi trying to think of a
way to make this idea popular and he
didn't get too much support but there
were a few people around the world who
kind of chimed in and took an interest
kid named marty malmy who uh lived in
finland was sort of struggling through
college and was one of the few people to
take an interest he was one of the few
libertarians in finland
and he that's that's not a particularly
like socially
you know useful position to have in in
finland so he had to spend a lot of time
alone and he
uh helped satoshi kind of drop the first
faqs on bitcoin in the first website and
the first logo and was also mining
bitcoin at that time and you know
if it had not been for
marty satoshi may well have just sort of
shut off the network and uh stopped
stopped the whole thing from from moving
forward
um
the uh that was sort of the first two
years of bitcoin at some point people
started trading them
paying you know 10 cents for them 20
cents for them
but really the first time it took off
was
the silk road which uh was this black
drug
online
black market for drugs
which was run by created by somebody
named the who went by the name dread
pirate roberts
and um this was actually uh you know a
lot of people within the bitcoin realm
try to downplay these origins you know
they want to focus on the sort of
socially useful applications of bitcoin
but um the reality is that bitcoin was
useful for sending money without an
intermediary and
um obviously
the people who are most interested in
sending money without an intermediary
are not
you know people doing legal transactions
credit cards tend to work for that but
buying drugs from across the world is
not as easy
and so this actually provided a first
use case and and it proved that silk
road proved that bitcoin worked you
really could send value across the world
and um you know people could send you
your drugs in return
and that went on for
two three years before the police found
ross ulbricht who was the dread pirate
roberts and shut it down
unsurprisingly
soon after shutting it down all of the
silk roads competitors sprung up and
there are now more
uh more online black markets using
bitcoin and other cryptocurrencies than
ever um and uh so this is still a kind
of central
application of of bitcoin but but
certainly not the only one it's and in
terms of overall transactions it's maybe
one percent of overall transactions but
in terms of sort of real-world economic
transactions the legal transactions are
pretty significant um so the the next
point at which that was 2011 that ross
olbert created the silk road the next
point it really took off was in early
2013 um that was the first time the
world kind of found out about it it shot
up to
something like a hundred dollars people
um attributed at the time to cyprus
cyprus's banks were getting um there's a
there was basically a run on cyprus
cypriot banks
actually a lot of russian money involved
but
that was actually the kind of given
explanation um at the same time that
this was happening in cyprus and people
were thinking oh you know banks are
troubled maybe these people in cyprus
will use bitcoin let's you know maybe
this has some value
um there was also a conference of
venture capitalists in allen allen and
co in sun valley where a lot where one
of the main sort of pied pipers of
bitcoin sold this to venture capitalists
and they all went to their hotel rooms
and bought millions of dollars of
bitcoin and it's actually always been a
question you know looking back at that
moment was it cyprus or was it these
kind of venture capitalists acting more
quietly
i mean when i
kind of hear
the the sort of uh thinking around
causality and how do you establish
cause
this is one of these questions where you
can dig into the data and try to
try to start to figure that out and uh
you know it's a question i think that's
still
open to me and there are a lot of points
like that in bitcoin where you have this
public ledger that might answer these
questions
obviously where we are
now things have moved far beyond bitcoin
we've moved to
ethereum which is a system
where not only can you send money
between addresses but you can establish
smart contracts between
addresses and encode them into the
blockchain so that you can have more
complicated programmable money and that
has given rise to decentralized finance
and
um there are exchanges where you can
trade um ethereum and other tokens or
bitcoin for each other without needing a
stock you know not not needing a central
organization like coinbase or you know
the new york stock exchange in the
course of in the case of stocks um
and um
this has this has given rise to this
this is one of these decentralized
exchanges uniswop
where you can trade back and forth
the
this has given rise also to this new
world of non-fungible tokens which is
these sort of art tokens that are traded
this is
again one of these things where you
uh you see a lot of sort of mockery of
this
but it also the nfts and we can talk
more about this if anybody's interested
but sort of point the way towards
owning your identity owning digital
assets online um
owning digital assets in a way that
hasn't been possible until now you know
traditionally if you own
say
uh a character in a video game you rely
on electronic arts or minecraft to sort
of store that character for you
and
if they want to deny you access to your
account that's they're allowed to do
that and uh nfts have sort of pointed
forward towards um a point where
um you know you can own digital goods
your identity your facebook identity
your twitter account without relying on
a company and you know after
twitter got in a position where they had
to basically delete the account of the
president of the united states it's easy
to imagine sort of future technology in
which people own their social media
accounts in a way that a twitter
wouldn't be able to delete them
and that's where
sort of blockchain technology and
thinking about this i think is head in
these days
so
that's uh a little bit on the on the
bitcoin story i'm going to sort of jump
here um i i i think that sort of
introduces some of the way that i have
thought about this story as a journalist
i've thought about it through human
stories but also through the data
but i also want to talk sort of a little
bit more broadly about
journalism about you know how
journalists think about things and how
they interact with scientists and and
and vice versa
so i uh
have been for most of the last decade a
reporter at the new york times which i'm
sure you all know the all the news
that's fit to print at the top
which is one way of stating the mission
of the times and
um and journalism i think it's actually
not a particularly good way
this does not at all define what uh ends
up in the newspaper every day uh it's
far from it um and i think it's useful
to just sort of
review
what ends up
what makes a story because i think it's
it's useful for thinking about you know
if you want to get your own story if you
want to get your own research out there
it's useful to understand sort of how
the news works also understanding that
is useful as a public citizen obviously
so i think you know i think for most
people there's this sense that sort of
that the times covers the events of the
day and just whatever the latest thing
to happen and in the broadest sense you
know that's
right now obviously they're covering
the ukraine and they cover the
presidential election and all these
things but that's probably you know 10
20 of the paper and you know when it
comes to things like coverage of science
and academia
it's not just the newest it's not just
the newest development or what happened
this week it occasionally is it's
occasionally there's some you know
controversy that the times covers um but
you know so much of what is in the times
is not the latest development or not the
most important thing in a field it is um
the sort of nature of the new york times
is covering um and the the the
new york times has been drawn to cover
because of their commercial model
essentially
what is the most unexpected development
in any given field
that you know in in relation to what
people already know about that field um
and so you know i i actually my first
job right out of college was in in
germany and you know there's a sort of
joke among journalists that you know in
each country there's like this limited
number of stories that you can write
about in germany
if you're writing for an american
newspaper you can basically write
stories about
jews nazis hitler and um very you know
the the angela merkel the
prime minister all of that sort of falls
down the list um
these are the things that american
newspapers are going to be interested in
japan you know we write about sort of
technology and old people and those are
the only stories that people think of
when they think of japan and so those
are the topics that the times is going
to cover heavily after
fukushima we would write about nuclear
reactors and japan and maybe world war
ii but there's a very limited number of
topics and it tends to be what do people
already know about this topic
um and then what's the sort of
unexpected twist on that um and that
that formula of sort of what is the
unexpected twist on something that
people already know about this topic
is
sort of this the the explanation for
about you know 50 60 of the stories that
go in the new york times including um
most of the ones that get the most read
and you know at the center of that is
this idea that there's
there needs to be tension in the story
every good story needs something that
people would not expect um or anticipate
um and i'll just you know cut back to
um when i was working at the forward
this jewish newspaper um i
one of my sort of big stories that
got a lot of attention was one about a
kosher meat plant that had these
terrible working conditions
they exploited
immigrants and paid them they used
underage workers and their sexual
exploitation
the reality is if it had been a normal
kosher meat plant
um i think this story
nobody would have paid attention
everybody sort of thinks kosher
meat plants are probably pretty ugly
places to work and people get injured
and there are a lot of immigrants and
that story would not have been terribly
interesting it was the idea that this
was a kosher meat plant um that was
supposedly responding to some sort of
higher ethic
that made this story interesting because
it was unexpected there was this tension
between what what you think kosher meat
was supposed to be and what was
happening at this place and this is the
sort of classic nut graph that you see
that you'll find in any
article anywhere which is you know
here's the first sentence is um here's
here's what you would expect it is you
know agriprocessors here's what you know
already it's kosher so it costs more and
it's held to a supposedly higher
standard
but here's the tension you know despite
those higher standards this place has um
you know just as bad standard or even
worse standards than traditional um uh
kosher or traditional meat plants
and so that idea of tension is going to
be there in almost every story and in
terms of talking to journalists and
selling journalists on stories
that is you know people often come to
journalists and say hey here's the
newest thing that's happening and every
journalist's eyes will glaze over
they're always looking for that but you
know here's what i expected and here's
here's what you're gonna uh here's how
you're going to
um
here's how you're going to surprise me
um tell me something unexpected so i
think that's an important idea to
understand that a lot of people don't
necessarily get coming in with
journalism and um that is um that you
know when when when dealing with
journalism when reading journalism this
is i think a really useful idea to have
in mind um but i also just wanted to
talk a little bit about how
the industry and the expectations for
the news industry are changing um
this has this may have gotten put in the
wrong place this was uh we can talk more
about the winklevoss twins and bitcoin
if you want but this was a piece of the
sort of human story and i think actually
um you know aside from the sort of
unexpected tension the other
the other stories that do well are
people stories you know people you know
and here's what they're doing
differently than you'd expect obviously
with the winklevoss twins people knew
them from the social network um and they
had established a reputation with mark
zuckerberg and for facebook and then
they came out and said you know what
we're pivoting we're going all in on
bitcoin um this was actually the first
story i wrote about bitcoin um and ended
up being the most read story for for
weeks afterwards but this combination of
celebrity and unexpected twists um is
you know one of these formulas that
newspapers
use
um i i think though that it's worth also
sort of talking about how the incentives
for the newspaper industry have changed
in a way that changes what the what is
the news that we get today um
this you know you've probably all heard
that
the news industry was decimated over you
know that 2005 to 2013 period google and
facebook came online
uh uh it first actually began with you
know craigslist they killed the
classified page which was this great
source of income for newspapers then
google and facebook come along either
eat up the
online advertising market and newspapers
nobody wants to read physical newspapers
and nobody's willing to pay much for
digital ads so you saw this very
precipitous decline
for a decade where
most newspapers shrunk by you know 50 if
they weren't destroyed completely
and this has sort of irrevocably changed
the news industry and the way news is
presented and what is a story these days
the response to this
this downward slope is that newspapers
moved to
instead of relying on
home subscriptions they and advertising
with home subscriptions um and the print
paper the way they made most of their
money was advertising they answered to
advertisers
as everything went online they realized
the only way we can make money is to
move to digital subscriptions and so now
the timezone is is making money and is
answerable to its subscribers instead of
to the advertisers um
and this would seem like a great thing
you know it seemed i think there was a
lot of criticism that newspapers had to
answer to
advertisers in the old model um because
advertisers could you know corrupt the
um
the the process they they would they
could have a voice you know if you don't
if you print this story this negative
story about us we're not going to place
an ad in the paper anymore now we've
moved to a system where
it is the subscribers that the times
relies on and the times needs to hold on
to its subscribers and grow its um
its subscribers if it wants to survive
and the thing that this new model
instead of the subscription model that
it now relies instead of the old
advertising model
do you want to
you know isn't it
i mean at the beginning of the last
century yellow journalism it was all
subscribers
and then
advertising sort of evolved and it
became advertisers and now it's kind of
come full circle in some ways it seems
to me i mean certainly advertising was
also you know a piece of
part of yellow journalism but but you're
right it's this is not an entirely new
um phenomenon it's just a change from
this sort of
allegedly sort of golden era of
journalism from you know post-world war
ii journalism where
newspapers became these sort of wanted
institutions um that were relied upon
and that's that's the role that the new
york times came to play and that's when
the new york times came to occupy this
and now the incentives have entirely
changed and have moved to subscribers um
and so now you know again this would
seem like a sort of
socially good turn perhaps um that peop
you know that it is the readers that
that newspapers need to answer to
um but what i think we've learned over
the last 10 years of digital
subscriptions and newspapers
is that people are only willing to pay
for a few things in journalism
and one of them is things they need for
work and so that has led to the rise of
um sort of industry uh publications and
um you know
bloomberg businessweek stat news is the
online um for for science and and and
bio medicine and you have now these
well-funded um publications that roll up
that are that rely that work in some
niche where it is useful to the jobs
that people do and that they can get
reimbursed when they get that
subscription so that's one sort of
journalism that's done well here
the other category that has done well it
turns out people are willing to pay for
stories that move them and sort of
affirm their identities and make them
feel good about who they are or that
make them feel angry at who they don't
like or who they are not you know it can
help to find their enemies um
and this is increasingly become the role
that the new york times has played
people the the the subscribers the the
stories that people want to read in the
new york times are often um stories that
um either are
human stories um that you know can touch
you and make you feel like you're
connecting with somebody or stories that
can make you feel anger and outrage you
can see from this cat this top
this list of the ten most nine most read
uh stories from last year um
most of these are more on the outrage
side than they are on the you know life
affirming you know mike pence reached
his limit um alex baldwin's gun the
racist oakland raiders emails the proud
boys mocking trump you know this is um
outrage outage shakes facebook like this
this um vaunted institution um so
um
uh yeah here we can i can cut in the
middle of this yeah no so i mean
what do you think about you
say songs kind of thesis around
that you know in her book what she talks
about
you know a lot of this journalism is
also targeted towards elites because
they're the only ones who can afford
to pay or are going to go subscribe and
it sort of becomes ever
sort of self self-self-reinforcing
yes yeah i mean that
yes
oh yes maybe i missed it but when you
say most read is it that people just
open it
and stay on the page like a 10 second
and you can't just read or retreat or it
is that they uh really read it deeply up
to the end this article yeah well
they're
this is the stories that were the most
clicked on last year so um there are
similar lists of the stories people
spent the most time with and those
tend to be and some of the most sort of
defining stories for the paper are these
long narratives you know these long
tails sometimes long investigation i
mean you know the times is so proud of
its investigative press
none of these most read stories are um
investigative stories that dig into
stuff they're things that sort of affirm
people's identities now the
investigations can have still a social
impact even if they are not the most
read so this is not you know the times
is still very much committed to doing
that but the incentives have
changed and you can see it in the
stories that people read and the stories
that people read are the ones that you
know editors inevitably want more of um
i um i should um i should say that you
know part of what's happened here as i
just indicated that this what people are
willing to pay for has created this
split
in um the journalism industry
where you have on one side you know a
handful of these national papers that
can um
that can that have the resources to
write these either long human stories um
you know this is where obviously
podcasts fit in things like cereal
that's obviously been a big money earner
the new york times has increasingly
moved to relying on podcasts and audio
that makes audio makes you feel and so
you you you will connect with that and
you will be willing to pay for that um
but the times you know when it comes to
sort of that funds all of the political
journalism all the investigative stuff
and there's really only a few
publications that that have managed to
capitalize on that you know they're
really three or four national
publications
wall street journal
potentially the atlantic the washington
post and then at the other side you have
the sort of rise of industry
publications you know wall street
publications like bloomberg
wall street journals is in in some ways
an example of that you know stat news um
and um and then in the middle everything
has just been hollowed out and you know
that's where local newspapers sit um
there they local newspapers have
continued to
decline um
and um
i
i
think for the sake of scientists part of
why this is useful to be
to know
is that
you know the new york times is is is has
a has a sort of waning or at least
limited appetite for science news and if
i were trying to get um you know
interest in
my research you know if i wanted to get
that out there you're you're likely to
come across much more knowledgeable
reporters people who are well-funded
these publications you know
um are i mean you know ours technica i
mean there's you know the sort of tech
world now has a whole universe of
publications that are inevitably or or
almost
um
definitely going to write more
interesting
stuff about your research and spend more
time if anybody is than is you know the
new york times and i think that's sort
of useful to know for journalists
i think niche specialty publications
have become
more important in the sort of
understanding of of specific topics than
national news organizations have and
that's that's um useful to know um i
think the sort of latest
development and i i actually should say
before
i move on um to that from that
discussion of sort of the incentives in
the news industry um i don't probably
this is no surprise but i think the sort
of academic
industry such as it is um you know has
similarly responded to the incentives um
in some of the same troubling way or in
ways that are perhaps equally troubling
to what has happened to newspapers
obviously
i'm not you know telling any
making telling you any surprises when i
say that you know that the academic
academia has become focused on
publications and tenure and not on
teaching not on sort of influencing the
public discourse
and i think that's meant that there has
been a divide between you know on the
one hand the public discourse and on the
other hand knowledge coming out of
academia
it's why you know the idea of bringing
journalists into universities
i think is a good idea to sort of get
them
understanding some of the work that's
going on here
and i think but i think there's this
chasm that separates the two um that may
actually be on display today in the lack
of an audience here um and i think that
that's it's a it's a telling chasm i
mean you know there are some places that
are more
um
more focused on
um sort of cutting-edge theoretical
stuff that the public is never gonna
understand and that is necessary and
useful and there's no you know but i
think there could be more of a
conversation i think you know academia
has sort of walled itself off in the
same way that um that the journalism
industry has sort of responded to these
populist
incentives that that they have and um
you know i think i i've certainly
noticed in sort of spending time here
coming back to campus after a while the
degree to which you know scientific
jargon and and sort of act the the
incentives of publications make it you
know often very hard to understand um
what is what is happening in the
academic world for anybody outside of it
um and you know this is in areas you
know computer science where obviously
these these this is this is important
this is defining the future this you
know sort of optimizing um
uh you know machine learning and and is
is these are all like ideas that are
going to have and you know important
implications for
um
for our first society so um there there
should be more bridges built
and i just just want to mention one last
thing before i you know open up if we
can have some conversation around any of
this um i do think um the latest
development um in the sort of
evolution of journalism is this idea um
you know sort of strange and not all
that apparently compelling idea but is
actually been quite important which is
the rise of newsletters like sub stack
you know twitter now has its version
review
ghost um
facebook has its version you know i
think at first everybody was like well i
mean it's just these are just emails why
would anybody uh care but it turns out
that um
uh all of the best not all of many of
the best journalists have realized they
can actually make more money going off
and starting their own newsletter and
having their own voice um then they can
you know getting paid a salary uh at by
the time that their value is greater
than what the times offers them and i
think it's off it's allowed journalists
to my my perspective on this i've become
a big fan of a lot of sub stack
newsletters there's there's a lot of
issues with them which people are
writing about these days but they offer
journalists an opportunity to be honest
and to speak without the kind of cliches
and jargon and um sort of con
constrictions uh restrictions of
newspapers which have these very narrow
ideas of what are stories and how
stories should be written so i think
this is important and it's also
important because it's allowed academics
to actually have a platform those who
want them so you see some of the
best-selling
most popular substance subscriptions are
actually professors who realize that
there is an audience that wants to learn
about these topics and you know gives
them total freedom to express that to to
experiment um
and i think you know it it it's
this isn't going to support the whole
journalism industry but i think it's a
sort of promising development
particularly when it comes to
um you know writing about
niche topics and um you know i think
that that people who can find a way to
communicate complicated topics to a
broad public now sort of have that
outlet without needing to you know get
through the editors at the new york
times so
um i am going to stop there and see if
anybody has any questions if we can talk
about any of the the wide variety of
topics that i brought up but first of
all thank you all for for for coming and
yeah i'm happy to answer anything
[Music]
oh are we using the mic
thank you nathaniel my name is steve
tedelus i'm an economist here at
berkeley
um and i have two questions uh
one kind of shorter
one that kind of has more meat behind it
the shorter one is
uh as an economist not computer
scientist i know enough about crypto to
kind of have an idea but i don't really
understand the nitty-gritty
as a journalist who covers science
technology
how deep do you go right at what point
do you feel like i know enough to convey
this to readers
and i don't know enough to really fully
understand it so that's my first
question
the second one is
related to what you just ended with
when i think of new york times
washington post other
major respected newspapers
i think of them
as gatekeepers of quality
right i rely on them to screen the
journalists
so when someone reports for the new york
times i'm like okay i trust this
not because i know who nathaniel or john
or jane is but because it's new york
times
when things get disaggregated like who
the [ __ ] is this person why should i
trust them where's the quality control
and i'm wondering if this is a very
slippery slope so curious your thoughts
on both questions
um
yeah and sometimes i think the second
one
is is yes is
more
he is almost uh was it easier to answer
or i mean the i i think
the the the issue with the new york
times and the issues i'm trying to bring
up here are sort of pointing out the
current incentives for the new york
times and the types of stories they
write
clearly
like being
getting the facts right is still
important they every time they have a
scandal where
some of their facts are not right it
does incredible damage to their brand
and their business
but you know we've seen many times i
think over the last few years where they
will defend things that actually aren't
right because
because um
and and which you know stories that they
wrote because they were responding to
these incentives they wanted to present
the story that would make you feel the
most and and get the most angry
and respond the most and you know the
headline that would that would evoke
that and i think that um you know as
long as you're
aware that those incentives are
there um you know yes they need to get
it right and i think that that's
you know they do have an infrastructure
set up to do that in a way
that not very many other places have um
i don't think that you know sub stack
can replace that
really what substack can do is provide a
place for people who have risen out of
that and established a reputation
as
reliable
and um
and i mean the people i read are not
people who you know just came at it from
from nowhere they're people who have
worked in these fields and maybe not
really had an outlet before to reach the
public i mean one of my favorite ones is
um
a geneticist who writes about you know
human evolution and in quite technical
terms and if he were doing this as a
column for the new york times the nuance
would get stripped out of it and because
it's on subsection he can just he has
the freedom to to do that and actually
actually developed a very large audience
for it now
um he is not going to get the kind of
editing and proofreading that the new
york times would have but i in some ways
he has more feedback from his readers
and is more responsive to his readers
because he's emailing them and they
write back to him immediately and you
know there's this thing that can happen
at the new york times where you know
somebody you write your story
you wrote most of it but your editor put
stuff in and you have to defend it you
because it's the paper that's going to
decide if they want to change something
and you might think you know what that
is wrong that's or that's not the best
way of saying it but that would revolve
a correction and so it doesn't get made
and so you know that's what goes into
down for posterity the newsletter writer
often the very next news letter will be
a conversation about you know somebody
people didn't like this line let's talk
about why that's true that doesn't
happen in the new york times um and so
you can have a more i think evolving
conversation i mean this is what you
know the early blogosphere i think also
offered and why it was so valuable um
that you know disappeared this is kind
of a return of that but you know it this
does not replace newspapers it does not
um you know it does not fill many of the
roles i think for things like
investigative journalism you need kind
of institutions and different areas of
expertise but um i think you know when i
want to read about the latest survey you
know
you know uh the latest public polling i
i would much rather read you know nate
silver sort of go back and forth or read
him debate somebody on twitter than read
a new york times story that kind of
presents one view and leaves out the you
know there's real disagreement about you
know this polling method or that iowa
thing really screwed up everything and
i'll get more of that from reading you
know that conversation than i will from
reading a new york times story about it
but it
requires a lot more investment um
obviously and and so you do get these
sort of specialized it's it's a much
more specialized world in which um
that information doesn't necessarily
sort of percolate up to the general
public so
and then on the bitcoin front i'll just
say um
i mean i am not a computer scientist um
over
you know covering bitcoin and
cryptocurrencies for six seven years
there have been a lot of points at which
i realized you know i don't really
understand this or i have to stop here
um
a lot of those points have been points
that i then you know so that okay i want
to understand i want to understand
you know the most basic public key
public-private key cryptography i mean i
think i get how that works um you know
you you at each point
you're writing a story and you realize
oh there's this technical thing that
actually matters and now it's time that
you know you understand that and and
usually you know if there is one
technical issue you need to understand
because it stands in the middle of this
you can get there you know you can um so
that that happens constantly but it's
often those things you don't you know
once they become important enough to
understand i think
um i mean even the most complicated
topics i think there's a way to often
eventually
get there if you need to and that's
that's one of the benefits of this rise
of specialty publications is that you
have people with
that expertise now because you don't you
know the new york times is famous every
three years you'd get a new beat and you
were a science reporter and then you're
in berlin and then you're in japan and
you didn't really know
the you know and i think we're moving
towards a more specialized world in
which people
are more likely to actually know the
topics they're writing about at least
for a lot of these
specialized publications so i'll
there was somebody else had their hand
up
either of these odd topics
um
so in all i'm just curious in all of
your
in doing digital gold and all of your
varied research besides dark money use
and
maybe money moving money from rogue
countries have you found a lot of
useful applications i mean there's all
these companies all this venture capital
all this money going into exchanges and
security and lending
and prices keep going up but i still
sometimes sit there and go
what's it all for like to what i i mean
there's lots of people driving
lamborghinis yeah i'm not but
in some like really you know in the
essence of it what's the lamborghini
industry
is an important one for you know
the italian economy so i you know i i
it's a good question it's one i have
asked all along um you know what is this
good for so i think the most basic
answer that you know bitcoiners will
give you um
is that for americans there isn't that
much use for this um
it doesn't do much that you can't
already
do with with digital money for somebody
in argentina or china or russia right
now i mean you know
russia make puts it in a different light
but there are a lot of places where the
government can come in and take your
bank account um or they the the local
currency can be inflated to away to a
point where your bank account disappears
and for somebody there
digital money that the government can't
seize
plays a more useful function and and
it's very hard to know how many people
are using it for that because we can see
that a lot of people for instance in
china have bought um bitcoin you know
china eventually tried to ban it they
the most they they kicked all of the
miners out of the country so but
certainly part of the reason it was
popular in china was because um people
were afraid of an authoritarian
government and wanted to have money in a
way that could move now is that because
they're evading taxes or because they're
human rights lawyers who are afraid of i
mean probably more evading taxes than
um you know trying to get to macau to to
gamble than there is you know artists or
human rights people needing to get have
their funds safe but you know that
that's there um i think over the last
two years what you've seen and this is
less with bitcoin and more with ethereum
and the competitors to ethereum um
is
a whole bunch of applications that
still are not widely used but that do
point the way towards an actual a
different finance a a different
financial system be a different form of
sort of
keeping track of our digital identity i
mean right now we we rely on facebook
or people who use facebook rely on
facebook
to manage their social identity people
on twitter i mean i have a twitter
account um with 50 000 followers
tomorrow twitter can just delete that
and i don't know who any of those 50 i
mean i know some of those 50 000
followers were but i don't get that back
i don't my whole history
of what i've written there
basically belongs to twitter and they
can delete it tomorrow um
if i had an account that i owned
um
i could you know if twitter makes me mad
or twitter does something irresponsible
i could move my identity over to another
system that's
you know owning your digital identity
and your sort of digital goods
is what this points towards and things
are starting to emerge with that i mean
i pointed towards non-fungible tokens
right now it seems like the most
frivolous thing people are trading you
know these images art sometimes they're
buying one of one art do they actually
own the art it's unclear but
they they own something that is sort of
they own this token that um can give
them access to things um give them
access to communities and you start when
you sort of play around with it you
start to understand how this might
become something that's more
useful and you're you're getting those
kind of applications um
and that you know facebook has obviously
bet its future on the metaverse um and
so basic if we all live in the metaverse
or some version of it or spend time in
it you know the question is do we want
facebook to own that or do we maybe want
to live
you know to the degree where any of us
are going to be in a metaverse do we
want to live somewhere where we're in
charge we own our identity we own
whatever expression we make there um
uh so this is all i think where this
potentially becomes useful you're
already seeing you know financial
transactions done without exchanges
there i mean there's a reason that you
know wall street and financial industry
is afraid of this and trying to get
involved because
it is already cutting them out to some
degree and that's happening um even when
you talk about trading of financial
assets um now it's it it is the current
what we have in cryptocurrency um is it
is it any better than the new york stock
exchange you can certainly argue but
it's it's creating a new a potentially
new paradigm so it's not it's not i
think uh just it doesn't just end with
lamborghinis
and so coming back to the incentive
story i was wondering about uh
polarization right so
we now seem to think mostly of social
media as drivers of polarization because
they also have this kind of incentive to
enrage people and make them angry so
what you're showing here seems to
suggest that even classical newspapers
are also contributing
to polarization is that true do you
think it
is
yeah i mean i think i think that the new
york times needs
to answer to its readers its subscribers
you know it it the near times i think
you know likes to argue that it is not a
sort of
liberal progressive newspaper but you
know there have been plenty of studies
done i mean the the readership is
largely progressive and does
want a paper that affirms
those politics and that sort of identity
and if you look through the stories
that's often quite clear
and
and it affirms sort of the worst thing
you think about the other side um you're
just you're not you know we there was a
time there's a sort of a famous story
where the new york times wrote a sort of
slightly
sympathetic
story trying to understand the sort of
an alt-right figure in ohio and it was
just like how could you ever write
about this person and give him a
platform and
you know i i would argue that the times
should have covered written more about
the alt-right before the rise of donald
trump and help people understand you
know why are people being drawn to that
um
it's it's harder for the new york times
to do that now with its subscribers um
with its reliance on subscribers i think
that's that's a real
um that's a real issue
[Music]
thank you guys for being here